[Music]
hi
my name is richard vogg and i'm happy to
be here and talk about how i became a
data composer
this ability of composing data or
creating data from scratch
has been increasingly helpful for me at
my last job i was working for a data
analytics company in chile for the last
years
and the client that we were supporting
with analytics was one of the largest
banks
in the united states similar to a music
composer
who assembles musical notes and chords
into melodies and songs
i started to play around with data sets
and using r it is very easy to get
started it is fun to get started
as many of you might also have
experienced
so for example it is very easy to create
a thousand random normally distributed
variables and we can also easily create
variables from other distributions
like the exponential distribution or we
can create categorical variables by
using the sample function
we can combine all those variables in a
data frame and then we have our first
in this case nonsense data set ready
and then we can go and take a look at
the data and we can
check if what we compose is actually
what we wanted to compose if it makes
sense so i started to
create small melodies small data
melodies in the beginning because it was
fun
and later because it was useful i used
the skill
in the business world to improve the
communication with non-technical
business partners so i created
small and easy data sets and
visualizations about topics that the
business partners felt comfortable with
and use them to explain concepts explain
methods
and in general to create a common ground
for discussion and for
questions when you compose a song
for your band it is not enough to have a
beautiful melody for each one of the
instruments
but you also want them to sound good
together
so in data words we do not only want
independent variables but we also want
them to make some sort of sense together
and i trained that skill and used it a
lot because we were working with
sensitive data
so you could not just send data to
someone else with a question
because not everyone had the same level
of access to the data
and instead i quickly assembled a
suitable data set for each occasion
and was able to ask questions but also
to give advice
without having to see the real data or
having to touch
the real data another application
emerged when we had more and more agile
projects
so we had this aim of having a working
deliverable
in each iteration and this was sometimes
hard to reach because we had to wait a
lot of time
for the data so we had to talk to the
data owner sometimes request
accesses we had to bring the data into
the right format
and by using a composed data set that
looked like the expected final data set
we could already start to work on the
output on the
report and why we were still
waiting for the real data and in the end
we simply replaced
that composed data set with the real
data set and improved the
whole process a lot when you want to
write a symphony you're not just
aligning a few instruments but you have
actually blocks or groups
of instruments that have to sound good
together
and in data words that could be a
database where you have several tables
that are all connected with each other
and it is not easy to create a complete
database from scratch
but we still did it to improve our
internal courses
so we wanted to make those courses
closer to what we actually
work with and we created a
client table transaction table account
tables
and combined all of them and made this
whole database available to everyone in
the company to the internal courses and
also
for small prototypes and projects
all this was about why data composition
is important
now how to compose with r there are of
course the distributions i
already showed in the beginning how easy
it is to to work with the distributions
and there are also a lot of functions
that can help you to correlate your
simulated data
to create those connections between the
variables there are functions that help
you to create the
relations between tables and of course
there are a lot of packages out there
that just wait to be explored that can
support you on
your data composition process
and as i just have a few seconds left i
wrote a blog post for each one of those
four points
you can i invite you to visit my blog
and there are a lot more details about
those topics
and i hope they might be helpful for you
to become a data composer too
thank you very much for your attention
[Music]